hey guys I'm Eric Bachman we just got
our first teaser for stranger things
season 2 on Netflix let's take a look
let's go my eggo
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay so even though this wasn't even 30
seconds this teaser threw a lot at us so
let's break it all down frame by frame
it opens with this awesome little wink
211th favorite food Eggo waffles with
this leggo my eggo commercial from the
year 1980 and just like season 1
everything in stranger things season 2
looks very 80s a decade a lot of us feel
nostalgic for even if we were born too
late to possibly remember it and fun
fact that actor there is Jason Hervey
aka Wayne Arnold the older brother from
the 80s 90s show The Wonder Years
which like stranger things was another
nostalgia driven throwback show except
without the whole monster from another
dimension thing now this commercial
glitches with overlaid images of this
spinning sign for an 80s era arcade and
an ominous red stormy sky will get a
better shot of this later but the big
news here is 11 live which shouldn't be
too much of a surprise because we did
see chief Hopper leave all those snacks
and Eggos for her in the woods at the
end of last season we hear the voice of
Mike wheeler call her name and the shot
of her eyes opening as her face is
upside down I see what you did there
also check out that bloody nose my guess
is this is 11 waking up in the upside
down moments after defeating the
demagogue and in season 1 so it seems
like in season 2 11 will still be a
major force in the story as the
mythology deepened the world expands and
the supernatural threats get a lot worse
we also get a look at the boys in the
most appropriate Halloween costumes ever
season 2 takes place a year after season
1 now in the year 1984 specifically late
October 1984 based on the date on that
security video that we see later
and since ghostbusters the movie came
out in summer 1984 obviously this is the
costume you'd see on pretty much every
group of for kids it's almost as if the
duffer brothers intended on one day
mapping Justin Mike will and Lucas over
venkman spengler fans and Winston not to
say Lucas has to be Winston you can't
really read their patches in that shot
and just like how seeds of one use the
boys Dungeons & Dragons game as a visual
metaphor for the story
I feel like season 2 might do a similar
thing with the ghostbusters like we know
that a portal to the upside down in the
lab is still open
be opening up the town of Hawkins to an
infestation of paranormal entities that
the boys have to round up but if you
will and perhaps one of those demonic
monsters will be a giant that threatens
to crush the town a pocket and thanks
that might be what we see in this
mysterious shot of hopper as something
smashes through the room that he's in
there's also a shot of hopper plunging
and shoveled downward maybe digging up a
grave or killing an interdimensional
insect or you know maybe just like
planting a tree or something we also get
this shot of a figure and a hazmat suit
similar to the ones we saw in season one
but this time with some real firepower a
freaking flamethrower perhaps inspired
by the ones an alien and alien you
should check out my other stranger
things videos where I talk about how
this show barred a lot of cool design
elements from those movies in particular
we also hear some panicked breathing by
a female character my guess is this is
11 maybe this is from when she's like
navigating the upside down I suppose it
could also be barb
hashtag barb live hashtag probably not
but and this season it looks like it's
going to be another kid undergoing
traumatic experiments whale buyers
remember the final scene in season 1
let's we'll in a very bad situation
copying up slugs and experiencing sudden
visions of the upside down and based on
wills apparent mental breakdown here
these side effects are almost certainly
going to get way worse and that brings
us to these epic final shot wills
drawing of a massive multi limbed
creature looming over the horizon seems
to come to life and since the show
stranger things is full of references
this could be referencing a few things
first off this shot of will in the
doorway is a clear reference to the
iconic shot in Close Encounters of the
Third Kind with a young boy looking out
his front door into the light of the
supernatural and this shot of the giant
monster with its silhouette lighting up
and lightning seems very similar to the
movie the mist which is an adaptation of
the book by Stephen King obviously
Stephen King's another huge influence on
stranger things and the mist is also a
story about a portal between dimensions
opening allowing violent monsters into
our world and some other people are
saying that this creature reminds them
of gareth edwards movies like the Muto
from Godzilla or the giant tentacled
monsters from monsters but my theory is
this creature is one of two things
considering last season the Dimmick
organ was based on a creature from the
Boise
the game in the first episode I think
this one might be the sessile Hydra
which was brought up in the DMV game in
the last episode the vessel Hydra is a
VND creature with 8 snake head based on
the Hydra from Greek mythology with
several heads that grow back whenever
you cut them off but based on its
massive size I think this could also be
inspired from the Eldrazi from The Magic
the Gathering card game
those are huge and tentacled and they
lay waste to the landscape similar to
what this thing looks like it's capable
of doing but of course this could all
just be a dream sequence or a vision but
come on
this is stranger things if it's just a
vision it's definitely a premonition for
something real come in and perhaps the
upside down was just a purgatory like in
between dimensions buffering in this
dimension from a deeper more hellish
dimension which could be the reason for
this terrifying fiery red glow in the
sky and the demonic beast that comes
with it whatever it is I just love how
the red glow of this storm leads into
the red glow of the stranger things
title updated with a big - underneath
the words similar to the title or scream
- and child's play - and speaking of
slasher movies it's ironic that they
show Halloween as the release date
because this whole opening title music
is clearly inspired from the synth tones
of John Carpenter's Halloween scores
[Music]
really I'm just excited to see how
stranger things uses the creepy feeling
from Halloween
there's just something dark and magical
about that time of year especially as a
kid and I feel like season two is really
aiming to take us back to the place and
all of our childhoods where little
things creeps us out and giant demons
from Hell tried to kill us so even
though Halloween seems like way too long
the way I say take your time tougher
brothers stranger things is worth the
wait and we'll just continue to rewatch
this teaser and react just like the
voice in the cast did when they watched
it okay check out my last Ranger thanks
video for my thoughts on the titles of
the 9 episodes in season 2 in fact I
feel like episode 5 the storm could be
connected to the storm we see in this
teaser and really if you love stranger
things you should definitely watch that
whole video as well as the earlier video
where I broke down all the references in
the first season and if you liked this
video please hit like and subscribe to
new rockstars and let me know your
thoughts and predictions recedes into in
the comments and if you really like this
channel you can contribute to us on
patreon thank you so much to all of our
current patrons especially Kenny Smith
you can hit me up on Twitter at EA boss
with any thoughts or questions or you
can follow new rock stars on Twitter at
new rock stars for updates on our videos
ok thanks for watching bye
[Music]